[Music]
what has this last two weeks been like
for you watching this unrest in our
country and everything play out Wow it's
been disturbing it's been troubling
troubling it has tapped into the rods of
emotions from anger to frustration to we
remiss to exhaustion because you know
I've been having the conversations even
before we got to George Floyd we had the
killing of Maude arborea down here in
Georgia and so just talking to people
particularly in the white community that
still didn't get it at that point who
now get it so it's it's it's been all of
that and and to think that these young
people over the last several years who
have been bringing to our attention over
and over again about black lives matter
and the need to have reform and our
police departments across this nation to
look at the issues of justice and equity
across all of America and our structures
and systems being that continual outcry
and now it's spilling over collectively
at the same time all over America with
those on the nonviolent protest side
with the presence of those who've
infiltrated from the extreme left
extreme right those that are intent on
destroying America I've just been saying
over and over again America we have a
choice to make
we can even continue on the destructive
pattern that we started our nation in we
were we were founded in violence we
perpetuated violence against the Native
Americans we perpetuated violence
against African Americans an oppression
and and and just cruelty inhumane
treatment and it goes forward through
you know Jim Crow is segregation and the
movement that my father led was a
disruption it was an interruption to get
our attention then to say hey we have to
reorder
we have to recognize the dignity of
African Americans and we have to make
sure that we include them in an
equitable fashion in an American because
we built the country with free labor
free labor and we didn't listen to his
voice and he told us knew that after you
got the Nobel Peace Prize we have a
choice we still have a choice and I'm
gonna say now we still have the choice
nonviolent coexistence of violent core
knowledge and it's right before our eyes
are we gonna choose the pathway of those
who've been on the streets of America
for the past six seven eight years
saying no justice no peace are we gonna
go down the pathway of those and then be
intent on destroying America which is a
pathway we kind of set up you know as
daddy said America being the greatest
purveyor of violence and so hey it's the
forest
I choose non-violence I continue in that
work I still believe in it I know in the
end that if we're gonna get to permanent
peace which means justice that
non-violence has to be the way to know
how he died hey the only thing that I
can do is you told a very poignant story
about watching George Floyd's daughter
and what you understood about her
situation I was five and my father was
assassinated brutally she's six so we're
the same age and immediately when this
happened and I heard that he had a six
year old daughter it took me back to
when my father was brutally taken from
us
and I just I I know the pain that comes
from that
losing the daddy it's such a young age
and the things that she's gonna have to
wrestle with in particular the anger and
and having to guard against hating my
mother used to always tell us in our
household we're not to hate the man of
the person who killed your father we're
not gonna hate the man and she said that
over and over again
and yet I went on a journey where I did
hate for a while I hated white people
and especially white males and that
journey was you in my 20s and into my
early 30s most people didn't know it
because of the kind of household I grew
up in but I was dealing with that and
the anger inside and the rage inside
we gotta change America I mean she said
it to us
my daddy changed the world she spoke
prophetically out of her mouth because
we will change the world now and it's so
sad but it always has to be something so
brutal why can't we just do the right
thing and I'm saying to my white
brothers and sisters come out of the
confines of your privilege all over
America this I'm standing side-by-side
and the social justice movement they've
done it since the 50s and 60s but
they're those in the places of influence
and power that had the choice today to
shift things and to change things and to
deal internally in their institutions
and their corporate environments to deal
with anti racism create an anti racism
environment the money is good it's
needed and should be invested and the
people who are doing this work but
internal change has to happen as well
heart change the structure change and
policy change there are so many people
both black and white that are looking in
different places to understand what is
the next step and what needs to happen
it's a lot of next steps but for my
white brothers and sisters do the anti
racism it has to be done the tragedy is
that we donate all this money and I'm
not saying don't donate the money
because that money is needed we got to
run parallel tracks that money is for
the real work of changing these
structures and these systems and
creating more just and equitable
circumstances but there also has to be
that internal work that happens because
otherwise we'll be putting a bandaid on
it and it come off so easily it'll just
happen all over again
even Kennedy has has a book around on
how to become an anti-racist because all
white people need to become an
anti-racist because believe it or not
unfortunately we grew up in this society
and our collective conscience if you're
on the right side whether you believe it
or not you're a racist we got to look
policy reform without police department
Obama was on the right track
with the 21st century report from his
task force we need to we need to be
encouraging and demanding that our law
enforcement community across this nation
begin to put those recommendations into
practice while we're changing some of
the legislation around chokehold and
excessive force extension what would you
say to the entertainment community and
how they can step up in this time I
would suggest that they use the
influence that so many people have the
ear of people who can make some changes
instantly use that right now
pick up the phone put the pressure on
we've got to see changes and the hot
button area is in this police reform you
know we've got it
sea entertainers need to be putting it
on to talk about this reform on all of
their platforms many of them are
connected to people are connected to
people who are legislators in Congress
who are who on the side that has for so
long denied us the opportunity to change
America use it like never before this is
not the time to be comfortable and and
don't just do the Facebook post don't
just do the social media post that's not
enough Hollywood also needs to begin to
use their creative platforms to tell the
historical stories and the current
stories you know I love entertainment
but this is serious now we got to put
out other other films other works
because there's something about the
power of media and entertainment in our
minds and people need to hear something
different that reflects the America we
want to be put out cameras that reflect
the America we should be my father wrote
a book where we go from get chaos a
community everybody pick it up he has a
blueprint in the back of that book that
had we've embraced back then we would
have seen equity coming our education
system in our housing system you know an
economic system and and so I'm
encouraging people to read that book
tell me about the virtual protest the
seven-day virtual protest
some people are still sheltered in place
in this nation some people are in areas
where they can't get to cities where
some of the the protests of being that
are going on and so we established an
online platform for people to have their
voices heard so so we're collecting
people's ideas and thoughts but we're
also focusing people on solutions so how
can people join in that seven-day
program they said the seven big protests
is that the king centers Facebook page
and on YouTube King Center I believe
it's on Twitter as well they could come
and join us 7 o'clock every night and
we're gonna just be hearing things that
you're saying we're gonna be talking
about some things we're gonna have
people popping in we have to continue to
raise our voices even online while
people are protesting in the streets in
the streets and clarifying some things
on those platforms as well
[Music]